what's up everyone we are back at Witte
we are now with mica Co Co hello nice
beer thanks for joining us on the show
thank you really appreciate it so oh my
goodness
okay so we got to dive into a Vinod okay
and this is a subsidiary of Accenture
yeah and Microsoft then a partner
together on a Vinod and so you are
focused on software deployment and
delivery yes and so you knew this 15
years post you yes close to 15 years of
software delivery and this is like for
banks and for nonprofits and for all
different types of agencies that really
like your skill set of delivery yeah
yeah
and so and your background is go through
your Chinese Filipino and you grew up
there your whole life yes the
Philippines your whole life and then
maybe start with tell us like about how
that was like and then when did you like
pick up coding and like management and
deployment and stuff like that and it's
interesting story Allen I actually never
thought I'd be involved in any sort of
technology right because growing up my
friends would ask me teachers even what
do you want to be when you grow up Oh
anything that doesn't have to do with
technology
I hated it I mean I wasn't very exposed
to neither of my parents were very tech
savvy and I wanted to be a lawyer or a
writer you know something in that vein
but later on when the IT boom was
happening there was almost a feel of
okay what is his about and then my
interest my curiosity took over and I
was actually taking up accountancy
initially mmm no offense accountants I
mean it just wasn't for me so I said
okay let's let's shift over to IT and
I'm glad I made that shift it wasn't a
natural fit at first but I worked on it
so I felt that the continuous learning
my drive to kinesin learn and evolve
worked well for me in this particular
field and I graduated from IT in the
Philippines summa [ __ ] laude and I
thought hey you know I actually really
really love this I grew to love it I
didn't initially love it and thought
this was what I wanted to do from the
beginning it's something I
love so this is a similar story to I
think myself and a couple other people
that I know actually a decent amount of
people is that the parents might not
have really had a background in the
field that we were interested in and
then there was this on a societal
pressure to like do like dr. Boyer kind
of those things and then just somehow it
ended up being that like we figured
something out that we really like to do
and then we ended up going with that and
so okay so now when you graduated IT and
then you decided to move to the United
States after working for a little while
I worked in the Philippines for a while
for Accenture which is I know one of the
top I saw work until consultancy
companies in the world I worked with a
variety of clients most of which I
cannot names you to NDS then I
eventually started working with a Vinod
which is the subsidiary of Accenture and
focused more Microsoft technologies
which was actually a good fit in my in
the beginning of my career but Accenture
the focus this morn non-microsoft you'll
see will actually became a Siebel
certified consultant and but I was more
inclined towards Microsoft because when
I was studying in school the
technologies we we barely honed in on
where Microsoft
leaning right like so sequel etc so when
I shifted job thought it was a bit of an
actual thing I'll say I enjoyed it so my
focus has been on myself technologies
and now the projects I work with use
Microsoft technologies primarily so so
as a like software deployment expert as
well as like a scrum trainer and these
types of things actually the first
female well either the first one on the
first professional scrubbing developer
dotnet professional scrum trainers when
scrum daughter I know that's a mouthful
but that's it that's important that's
the you you're part of the see it be it
you know other young women look get a
look up to you and say I can do that too
so okay now what does that what does
that look like and feel like when you're
working with
these teams what is what is the go maybe
what is scrum - what a softener to point
what does that look like well you know
scrum it is really interesting because
it's one of the agile methods right but
you here
agile it's it's really an umbrella term
talking about a disciplined approach in
deliver and developing and in managing
software's and as long as it's
team-based I turret of collaborative its
agile so it's an umbrella term we have
Kanban you have scrum you have XP of a
number of methods and frameworks under
agile and scrum the one I hone in on is
very interesting because so agile itself
is a more of like an umbrella term that
for software deployment no for software
it's it's a delivery approach that is
that promotes disciplined management and
development okay which is team-based
itare attempt and collaborative yes yes
like what else is there besides
team-based well you'd be surprised
because I mean I mean I don't know how
young you are but maybe for your
generation that's already the norm yeah
what was it before that before our fault
right so the agile manifesto is actually
they it they came up the thought leaders
in the agile space came out with the
agile manifesto of 2001 so close to 20
years ago and before that most software
delivery and development was waterfall
so you have their stage gates very
defined silos plan analyze design build
test deploy right so every you can't
build software until you're done
planning you can't then you go to
analyze you analyze your requirements
then you design it then that's when you
build it that's when you test them in
you deploy so it would take like the
normal development cycle around a year
maybe six months to a year maybe more so
not like now when you have like two
weeks one months I mean what months
two weeks to one month in terms usually
in terms of you know the duration to
deploy software right where everything
is done within two weeks within that one
month right and that's the norm that I
say this generation is poly more
constant - yeah yeah but before that
yeah it was very defined we could
because you want to know if it's gonna
work or not
exactly and it seems like common sense
now but but 20 years ago it wasn't and I
think that's the thing the industry
leaders you know a thought leaders
really came together and said you know
the way we're doing things is
working so what do we want what do you
want to do it that's why they came up
with agile manifesto which really says
individuals and interactions over
processes and tools processes and tools
are important but individuals
interactions are more valuable right so
working software over comprehensive
documentation because during the time of
waterfall there's other lots of
documents design documents requirements
documents I want through several reviews
and sign offs and whatever and sometimes
you know it's after a certain period of
time that's all you have you have great
documentation on requirements and design
and whatever but you don't have working
software so hey hey we want to put a
premium working software over
comprehensive documentation right then
there's also you know over contract
negotiation we want to put a premium on
customer collaboration because back then
since it was so siloed and it was just
all about documentation again we have to
make sure the contract is airtight so
they put a premium on that versus
collaborating with the customers really
establishing that relationship and the
final tenant I'd say in the agile
manifesto would be responding to change
versus following a plan right because
back of that back of that journey day
the taste of waterfall - things change
so you got a pivot but success was
measured back then by how well did you
stick to the plan how compliant are you
to the plan
are you which right I mean they'll line
your for failure then yeah it's common
sense to us now but back then
interesting because yeah back then maybe
change was more perceived as the markets
moving we don't know how it's moving
stick to the plan we don't know what's
gonna happen but now it's like the
markets moving what's happening in the
market let's see if we can change
whatever we're building to make it
applicable to the market they respond to
change over following a plan I mean
they're still planning of course I'm
scrubbing in agile you plan you have but
just enough you know in time planning
just in time planning and that works
much better because imagine like back
then and I know I'm sorry if you can
edit this is going a little bit - too
much - you know it's good it's great to
learn about what a software engineering
used to be like compared to now yeah I
mean let's say if you had a month to
plan a month to analyze a month to
design I mean that's just a very
you know basic examples for simplicity
so at three months all you had again
were the requirements and design
documents he had no software and but
back then to them sometimes they viewed
it as successful we have great design
documents you know there you are signed
off there they look good blah blah blah
and I'm like yeah but where's where's
the real value by your client gets its
value from software that it actually
uses and something the market getting
feedback taneous Lee so yeah I mean it's
all common sense now and I'm glad that
this is the norm and I don't want to be
like a waterfall of a sure I think
waterfall and some scenario still has me
so has merit right but it's just that in
today's world excuse me
agile just makes sense yeah so okay so
now we have agile and it's able to be
more iterative and collaborative and
adapt to different market movements
faster and then we have subscribes
within agile and services frameworks
okay so teach us about that yeah and
it's um so scrum is a framework where in
which people can solve complex adaptive
problems while creatively and
productively I'm delivering value to
clients right so it's it's not just for
software I'll say although the focus has
been on software but you can use scrum
for non software activities even for
your daily life right so um excuse me
describe is actually relative relatively
simple it has a certain set of roles
events and artifacts they should just
need to be aware of but at the same time
I kind of liken that to chess you know
like chess the rules are simple right
I mean this piece can move you know what
are certain movements a certain pieces
can make but just traffic tries to win a
chess this is a different story so scrum
well simple to understand it can be
difficult to master
so scrum you have three roles the
product owner the scrum master your
development team know back then those
terms were kind of uh you know what's
that but now I think again you probably
hear that so often now right
master productivity vomiting and then
excuse me and then you have a sprint
right we should say okay you have it
your eye tration right if you have a
two-week sprint anything less than 30
days really 30 days or less so you know
scrum is is pretty simple right it house
rolls artifacts events but then I liken
that to chess which has rules that are
quite simple but in order to win the
strategy the execution it's really
different so much from you know you have
simple things to remember it's a simple
framework to understand but to master it
is really quite difficult so we have
three roles to part-owner scrum master
and your development team provides your
product owner is responsible for the
what what is division you know what is
the goal for the Sprint how do I
maximize the value in the product that's
really for deposit owner then we have
development team which is responsible
for the how like how do we execute the
vision of the product owner how do we
develop that then we have our scrum
master which is who is responsible for a
scrum like this is team really executing
scrum properly following the rules
making sure the events are actually
taking place every sprint so that's your
scrum master scrum stand for and it's
not actually any sort of acronym it's
you know you know how in rugby tour it's
like a scrum it came from that like oh
um you know how scrum is our quick and
you just talk you you talk about what
you want to do right and then you eat
you execute it do it yeah yeah and it
got its inspiration would be okay cool
yeah and then so if you have a sprint
which is like your your your entire
duration of your development for that
period 30 days or less so we can happen
why don't we spent two weeks three weeks
four weeks whatever works for your team
depending on a number of factors and so
when you talk about I say I'll say
probably the most common is two weeks in
practice so say a two-week sprint so in
that two weeks again unlike waterfall
before wearing wound at two weeks I know
maybe have one design document done you
have working software by the end of two
weeks and you have a number of events
that you have to do is you have your
sprint planning you know you you sit
down together the development team the
scrum team actually together talks
through okay
the product owners goal like this is my
sprint goal for a sprint this is what
want to happen but this is the result
that I want to achieve and then as part
of that goal the team then works
together understanding what's what's
really what are the items in the product
backlog or the product backlog items I
can help us realize that goal of our
product oh let's let's collaborate and
then there's negotiation between the
product owner and development okay okay
this is doable in two weeks not really
maybe we can swap it out for something
else that will still allow you to sprint
goal maybe we can break it down to
smaller chunks of work and just commit
to the smaller tikka for etc so that you
plan and short you plan for what you
want to deliver in that two weeks right
and after you're done planning then you
have your daily scrums
or excuse to me called stand-ups but
they're not called daily scrums work for
time box it's 15 minutes no more 15
every day time box is like um maximum
duration for something so I would say if
I time back this conversation to 15
minutes so time boxing is a big thing in
scrum so everything terms of the events
like the Sprint is really built around
concept as a time box so instead of you
looking at the work and saying okay I'm
gonna get this done in I know five
months in total you're thinking more
okay within the time box of the stays in
two weeks is it four weeks what of that
what item or items of value
can I really deliver [ __ ] a client if
it's focusing on that because you have a
shorter feedback loops to inspect and
adapt
I just wanting to change getting things
to market faster so sorry so do you want
me to go through scrum a little bit more
or a little that's that's pretty good I
know there's a lot more but wait to go
from waterfalling to all the scrum like
super fast action and also to like know
how to time box things too
to know how to dedicate like a project
visionary versus the developer is like
how those things go hand in hand that
that is all very interesting is is there
a certain like secret sauce that
different company
Jews have that they use with this scrum
agile who I mean you know part of the
problem is people think that you know or
used to think I don't know I think in
some cases it's still thought that agile
or scrum equals silver bullet or magic
bullet right if there are dysfunctions
and organization it will surface it
those sooner it won't and that's how we
can help I suppose to fix them earlier
because they're servicing them earlier
the secret sauce is the culture it's
really the people I say and that's one
of the reasons I really also gravitated
towards crumb because it respects people
more than proceeds I mean the proceeds
is there to guide but it's so
lightweight that it's really on the
people to establish that culture of
transparency inspection in that and
adaptation have have that collaboration
and continuous learning and that's why
some organizations have such a hard time
I honestly adopting you know more actual
ways of working it's because the culture
and the mind frame changed it just isn't
there
right as I said the rules are easy right
it's very simple really but because it's
if the people are not cooperating or not
on board or not along for the journey
then it's just not it's just not not
going to work so secret sauce I'd say as
corny as it may sound or as cliche I'd
say it's really the people it's the
people's people working together to
build that way you set out to do now
what about as you've implemented this
into telecommunications and banking what
does that look like um I will say that's
for you know for a majority of to
telecommunications work I did that was
more a part of a career when it was more
waterfall so I don't know I'm not
exactly sure how interesting relatable
examples for people to understand how
maybe like and the engineering processes
for a software deployment ended up
giving us telecommunications ended up
giving us some baking infrastructure
stuff like that Oh whatever you're
allowed to say
they might have to think about that so
yeah it's my favorites on video I'm
gonna be like oh hey we caught you on
tape say um so I mean I guess without
being very specific about the industry
could you rephrase that again what
exactly do you want me to to talk about
her to share um may be relatable
examples of the suffered deployment so
let's say if you're working on a
customer relationship management system
right and you have the accounts section
of your customer relationship management
system then then you know you focus on
that and say okay maybe my sprint goal
is to improve the account services
experience for my customers that's your
end goal and then you get your product
backlog items that will meet that
springle how do you how do you improve
their experience right around account
services for customer relationship
management system and then you take all
the PDI sort backlog items for that
develop it right and probably maybe
could mean redesigning the the accounts
page to remove irrelevant feels and then
to make certain fields mandatory let's
say are required and then you address
those and they at the end of your sprint
you you show that to your customers and
hey you know this will improve your
accounts and services experience we
improve the accounts page you know to
remove the redundant feels a relevant
field so now it's it's you know just a
few fields that are really needed and
then also we're preventing users from
saving of deform incorrectly so we made
some fields that should be mandatory
mandatory so and you need to demonstrate
that and it doesn't sound like a lot but
at same time there's there is
incremental value right so little ones
little any building on that until at the
end at the end of six months you see wow
you know in a span of six months in a
number you know through several Sprint's
that were two weeks long little chunks
of value but by the end of six months
Wow versus
again if me you were doing water hole
and then of six months maybe you're just
starting to starting your build phase
you're just starting to build there's a
something that about the description of
the way that the data is made readable
by us the way that we read the data and
interpret it and analyze it so if there
are ways to deploy software and that
make it easier for us to read and
interpret analyze the data then I think
that enables us to better achieve the
goals that we are setting with the
customer so with the customer
relationship management tool that you
just described with the accounts fields
like that makes a lot of sense that's a
good one there's there another one on
the top of your head that might let's
him
nap for four major retailer right which
I actually was a user myself and they
need to improve the overall experience
the mobile experience right um just just
two so I mean there was too many areas
and and overall we wanted to increase
the value of that application period
isn't this the application
it's not giving the values that you want
because supposedly it's supposed to
entice your customers to shop more right
because it makes it things easier
there's a better interface etc but that
particular application was not meeting
the needs because it was unreliable kept
crashing I kept restarting etc so again
maybe in that example what does the
Sprint goal so to improve the
reliability of the mobile application
and then how do you do that then you
pick the product backlog items that will
address that so whatever remediation you
need to do in order to dress that you
picked with PDI's and then you go
through the Sprint you develop you
deploy and by the end of say two weeks
three weeks you can show your client a
more reliable more stable mobile app
that maybe then add features necessarily
right but you did improve the
reliability of mo lova now yes yes
that's to be able to find the points
within the experience designed for the
customers that are using the product and
make it more reliable for them to use
and make it more effective for them to
use that that process no matter what
service industry retail industry is just
time times the most valuable thing we
have and if you can save time in these
processes heck yes okay so maybe we now
ask you about the importance of
uplifting women into technology roles
tell us about that well I think it's
extremely important specially at the
stage right everything is about
technology pretty much and we're gonna
it's gonna keep happening it's gonna
keep evolving in that direction and and
it's surprising to me really just the
fact that
we still don't have as many women in
leadership roles or even women just in
the practitioners area of Technology so
I think it's important as women we
continue to inspire each other we we
share experiences we share our struggles
Bashara wins and I think that's one of
the things that women in technology
international really excels in I mean
this is my first year actually
participating in any capacity and I when
Peggy Kilburn reached out to me and said
hey you know we were interested in and
getting you to talk and be part of this
Women in Technology summit this year I
really just jumped at the opportunity
because I wanted to be able to talk to
the women and share with them hey from
my personal experience I also
underestimated myself I thought oh I'm
not technical enough I I didn't you know
I'm I'm I just there were so many doubts
and and that's one thing that we women
unfortunately I mean you get better at
because we we're very good at under
estimating our strengths and so I think
that coming together nap lifting each
other is a great way for us to remind
each other of our strengths and and if
seeing somebody succeed at it right
services inspiration as an example and
as really as an indicator of yes it is
possible and focusing on the possible
especially in the realm of Technology
yes what's something that women are good
at and should continue to work together
so that it can become a bigger reality
for more of us sorry I don't know if I I
love that answer yes it's been so long
that we haven't had a avid congregation
of especially women and males that care
about bringing together with everything
that allies in the movement yeah and I
think now more than ever the feminine
energy is very much needed for the
planet and I think we're there were
there we're growing it and it's it's
gonna be some cool dance that happens in
the future I'm really excited for it
okay let's ask you about I mean let's
ask you this question because you spent
you spent about 25 years in the
Philippines is that about ish no well
let me think actually
I reveal my age if I say something but
here yeah so that's a that's a good
chunk of human life to spend in another
place in the world
so my question that is how do we balance
the we are one mentality with the
geopolitical leadership that is a hard
question um I don't know if have a
really good answer I mean there will be
nuances and differences based on
geography right I mean cultural things
such as um you know ass full pants or
maybe even Asians in general if you tend
to be more timid less aggressive in
terms of pursuing things it's just very
cultural and I think we are evolving and
we are becoming more empowered to you
know take opportunities and make
opportunities for ourselves but you know
those kinds of differences I can see it
but if we're talking about geopolitical
leadership are we talking about you know
where you know precedence government or
are we more in the direction of
leadership and well use geopolitical so
sorry I don't know it's it's a very
difficult question that we've been
asking for a while and it's uh that
that's kind of one of the themes of our
show is to ask very difficult why it's
fine and I like different but I just you
I might not have the answers but and
that's also okay people to just be like
you know what I don't know
here's something that I'm thinking about
that right now peace out well it's
getting support right support for
technology sector by the government that
is important I don't know if I'm
necessarily I don't want to be and I'm
not pinning it on any administration in
particular I'm saying in general I don't
know or I can't really say if I feel
that the support of the government has
been very strong for the industry sector
yeah and and and that that
that plays a part right so how much
funds are getting allocated to actually
building out the youth like educating
them from them from you know when
they're young so that it's not just BAM
welcome to the world I'd say that we are
we have a lot of great talent and even
Philippines I mean and I'm not saying
that because it's something I should say
I am mean that we have some totally
great talent there but every place in
the world has great talent absolutely
but I think that just there's just
different levels of opportunity right
yeah I mean where you are and I think
that right now let's say opportunities
that I have here versus in other parts
of the world well I'm I'm taking
advantage of them and in that I you know
and they're because they're here but
they're not necessarily always present
is their present world and I think
that's why people still want to go and
you know title to find opportunities for
themselves which they might not find in
them wherever they are yeah I just
rambled there no the opportunity is so
crucial across the planet this the best
way for people to actualize is to have
as much opportunity as possible for them
to play with and interact with and then
figure out what really resonates with
them and bring that to the world when
there's malnutrition and not not no
electricity and these other kinds of
issues it isn't it doesn't enable people
to actualize um couple rapid-fire
questions on the way out okay all right
what do you think the most beautiful
thing in the world
family family love I'm I'm I'm a very
sentimental and romantic person so sorry
but what is it about love and family
it's because totally don't let me
started I'm sorry actually I mean off I
don't know if I ain't gonna edit this
out or not but this me doing witty was
actually very important for me as
personally because some is first time
since my dad passed
then I really started doing these kinds
of talks again so um it's kind of just
it weird intercept oh my god okay
please sign itself I think that is it
that what makes it so wonderful to me
Arab why answer guys because I I grew up
a lot of love and um I think that sorry
[Music]
take your time you know this opportunity
or me being the way I am turning all the
way I did which bullied up your problem
because because I grew up with that you
know love and you know what I was lucky
enough to marry my my high school
sweetheart so I don't have any bad
dating stories or broken heart story the
uterus I mean I feel like it's beautiful
maybe because I was fortunate enough to
have been surrounded by it all my life
you know
yeah that's wow that that's right that's
right having family and love around us
is one of the best ways for us to feel
ya feel like the world is working part
of it maybe that's why I'm sewing and
abashed romantic and sentimental person
ease I mean you know I mean this is
creepy I don't it out of it is my dad's
ashes
don't apologize at all the the these are
the real raw moments that are really
important to share the moments of being
okay with being vulnerable the moments
okay with crying then we've done them
before on the show even I have a lot and
I think it's really really important
it's the realness you know do you do you
think that were alone in the cosmos
no I'm sorry I mean controversial or not
I believe
even life outside our life do you think
that we're in a simulation I wouldn't
rule it out but I don't know I just feel
it I choose my reality that isn't my
reality so would it would it affect me
so much if I'm saying it I was like neo
and I don't realize so you've been a
matrix to all the time.i it's not a
great answer and it probably maybe he
did it but I always I do wonder I don't
know if I have the answer but I do
wonder if if I ever did realize it hey
I'm in a simulation why I want to end it
because me selfishly I mean I I like I
like what I have in a simulation
selfishly yeah so I mean I'm a very good
simulation right right so be honest you
know he said it raw real honest yeah I
mean I mean honestly I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to you know got unplugged
but I'm not saying I would either I mean
something I would seriously think about
thank you for teaching us so much thank
you and I apologize for you're good
you're good you taught us a lot we have
very ignorant about software development
and how we even got in deployment how
even got to where we are today and that
is typically what ends up happening with
the next generations that come is there
just given that the iPad and they just
start swiping on and they don't even
know how it works and so to know how we
actually got here and the tools that are
used today in order to and the processes
that are used today in order to make the
suffer deployment actually happen
quickly and efficiently is so important
that was a great learning experience for
us thank you thank you if you guys had a
good time tuning in please give us a
comment below with your thoughts we will
have links in the bio as well subscribe
calm
like on the video share the video
content don't just consume this go
create with it as well go ahead and make
something with it video blog post etc
also join us on patreon help us out help
us continue bringing the equipment out
to really cool conferences and doing
great interviews of smart people so
thank you very much for tuning in and
peace out from Woody thank you
you